what is going on everybody welcome to
another Python with PI QT for tutorial
video in this video we're going to be
talking about the conversion of this to
the more typical structure you're going
to see which is going to be using
object-oriented programming but most
importantly defining our own app class
which just so happens to inherit from Qt
GUI so I'm going to go ahead and just
delete this stuff but you'll see the
same kind of names that you've been
seeing so why are we using object when
you're programming specifically or why
do I definitely want to push it here so
typically the stuff that I do is more
more notably like data analysis stuff
like that and in that scenario it's not
you use a lot of things that are object
or in your programmed like modules and
stuff like that and I'll explain why in
a moment over the most part you can
program in line and it doesn't really
matter and Python isn't is a language
that's read line by line so that's why
people use like functional programming a
lot
so why object-oriented programming makes
a lot of sense in anything that is going
to be interacted with so this is stuff
like games gooeys modules that sort of
thing where you've got someone who might
interact with it in a very dynamic way
so you want to be able to make it
dynamic and object oriented programming
is one of those ways to make something
very dynamic yet with not so many lines
okay so if you're not familiar with
object-oriented programming I do have a
crash course for it you can come to
Python programmer net dashboard search
object object drawing a program crash
course this one is with tkinter but it
doesn't really matter you can follow
this one along pretty much with whatever
you wanted tkinter just makes sense but
I would go through this if you're not
comfortable with things like inheritance
why we use self are kwargs parent
children that sort of thing so if you're
not familiar with that check that out
methods and everything otherwise let's
get started so we're going to go ahead
and first let's create a class we're
going to call this class
we're gonna call it window and window is
going to inherit from QT GUI q main
window now it's my experience here
you'll inherit your main application
will probably always inherit from this
but you might also inherit from QT
widget like we did before but for the
most part that's probably what you're
going to inherit from now a first thing
that we're going to do is create our
init method so define underscore
underscore init underscore underscore
and then of course we'll pass the
obligatory self and what do we want in
this application well immediately what
we need to do is to super the window
self and then dot underscore underscore
init underscore underscore empty
parameters now why are we doing that
well with super what we return is the
parent object and so our parent object
would be a cue main window object so
just keep that in mind and next what we
want to do is let's go ahead well use
the same kind of geometries before it
now remember how we did like it was
window dot set geometry and then the
parameters well now that we're using
object-oriented programming we can
always reference the window with a self
okay
so self dot set geometry 50 50 500 300
okay so start X start Y with height now
what we're going to go ahead and do is
we'll do the same things before self dot
set window title and again this will be
pie cutie
tuts okay now we can do something else
and we can do set window icons so
besides moving to object oriented
programming let's add some imagery so
self dot set window icon and then to do
this we'll use QT GUI cue icon and then
you specify the name of the icon how is
it that was odd I guess does that thing
popped up it didn't finish it's a little
formatting let me pull up let's do here
and here here and here is where we're
programming right now so let's add a
little image so the easiest thing to add
would be like a little Python logo like
we have on the website so let's just
steal my little Python logo off Python
programming net here and actually it's
not even my logo it is the Python logo
so go static Save icon dot ICO we'll
click on that and there we go so now I'm
just going to click and drag that for
whatever reason when I click and drag
this it saves it as a PNG so you've got
fav icon and it's dot PNG now even
though it's an ICO probably because it
really is a PNG and I just called it an
IC o---- but if you're says dot ICO
change it to a dot PNG and it'll be fine
so now this has fav icon let's just call
it a Python logo instead and then we'll
come over here and then call this will
do the cube icon is Python logo dot PNG
and then again we need to do a self dot
show and that's that and we'll come over
here we'll do the same thing as we've
done before we're going to say the app
equals Q T GUI Q application and again
we pass this dark V no different than we
did before and then we're going to say
the will say GUI equals window and then
finally we'll run that sistex 't stuff
so app dot exec underscore empty parms
and that's that let's go ahead and run
that and see if this worked to our
liking there we go got a window we can
see that the icon has changed and
otherwise it's pretty much the same
window that we saw before but now we're
using object or any programming and now
as time goes on we'll be able to modify
this window based on events from the
user and it will just make a lot more
sense that's why we're using
object-oriented programming most people
I'm sure won't complain but a lot of my
viewers are probably used to me not
using object or any programming because
sometimes it can make things more
confusing but I'll try to keep it as
simple as possible
so anyways that
is our move to object-oriented
programming now in the next video what
we're going to be talking about is
really the next thing I always think of
when I'm making a window is like I don't
make a button so we'll be talking about
buttons in the next video and after that
button events and all of that so if you
have any questions or comments up to
this point please feel free to leave
them below otherwise as always thanks
for watching things for all the support
and subscriptions and until next time